[Music]
it begins with a bit of discomfort and
soon becomes a pressing sensation that's
impossible to ignore finally it's all
you can think about and out of sheer
desperation you go on a hunt for a
bathroom until humans should urinate at
least 4 to 6 times a day but
occasionally the pressures of modern
life forces us to clench and hold it in
how bad is this habit and how long can
our bodies withstand it the answers lie
in the workings of the bladder an oval
pouch that sits inside the pelvis
surrounding this structure are several
other organs that together make up the
whole urinary system two kidneys two
ureters two urethral sphincter x' and a
urethra constantly trickling down from
the kidneys is the yellowish liquid
known as urine the kidneys make urine
from a mix of water and the body's waste
products funneling the unwanted fluid
into two muscular tubes called ureters
these carry it downward into the hollow
organ known as the bladder this organs
muscular wall is made of tissue called
detrusor muscle which relaxes as the
bladder fills allowing it to inflate
like a balloon as the bladder gets full
the detrusor contracts the internal
urethral sphincter automatically and
involuntarily opens and the urine is
released
whooshing downwards the fluid enters the
urethra and stops short at the external
urethral sphincter this works like a tap
when you want to delay urinating you
keep the sphincter closed when you want
to release it you can voluntarily open
the floodgates but how do you sense your
bladders fullness so you know when to
pee inside the layers of detrusor
muscles are millions of stretch
receptors that get triggered as the
bladder fills they send signals along
your nerves to the sacral region in your
spinal cord a reflex signal travels back
to your bladder making the detrusor
muscle contract slightly and increasing
the bladders pressure so you're aware
that it's filling up simultaneously the
internal urethral sphincter opens this
is called the Mik duration reflex the
brain can counter it if it's not a good
time to urinate by sending another
signal to contract the external urethral
sphincter with about 150 to 200
leaders of urine inside of it the
bladders muscular wall is stretched
enough for you to sense that there is
urine within at about 400 to 500
milliliters the pressure becomes
uncomfortable the bladder can go on
stretching but only to a point
above 1,000 milliliters it may burst
most people would lose bladder control
before this happens but in very rare
cases such as when a person can't sense
the need to urinate the pouch can
rupture painfully requiring surgery to
fix but under normal circumstances your
decision to urinate stops the brain
signal to the external urethral
sphincter causing it to relax and the
bladder to empty the external urethral
sphincter is one of the muscles of the
pelvic floor and it provides support to
the urethra and bladder neck it's lucky
we have these pelvic floor muscles
because placing pressure on the system
by coughing sneezing laughing or jumping
could cause bladder leakage instead the
pelvic floor muscles keep the region
sealed until you're ready to go but
holding it in for too long
forcing out your urine too fast or
urinating without proper physical
support may over time weaken or overwork
that muscular sling that can lead to an
overactive pelvic floor bladder pain
urgency or urinary incontinence so in
the interest of long-term health it's
not a great habit to hold your pee but
in the short term at least your body and
brain have got you covered so you can
conveniently choose your moment of sweet
release
you
[Music]